大家好,现在我来给大家介绍一下店群模式下怎样进行手动同步数据。
在之前的介绍中,我们已经设置好了店群,有主电和分电。
接下来我们要进行手动同步数据。
手动同步数据主要用在商品的一些数据属性,
例如图片，组图，价格，描述，做了一些变动。
那么想把这些变动被同步到另外一个店铺的对等商品上。
这个时候我们要用到手动同步。
我们首先需要创建一个同步的规则。
这边要绑定模式，有两种。
第一种是用商家编码，如果您这两个店铺的对等商品。
商家编码是相同的并且在整个店铺里都是唯一的。
那么您可以用这种。
另外一种就是您可以选择用实时同步处的所配置的关联关系来做绑定模式。
就说在它的下面这个菜单里,那里是可以设置它的关联关系的。
如果那里有的话,您也可以用这种。
我们先来用商家编码。
这下面的话,您是需要设置的,就是说我要同步的一些数据。
比如说要同步商家家的状态,或者说库存变动了,我叫同步库存。
或者说SKU,用的比较多的,比如说主电的这个宝贝它添加了SKU,
我也要把它同样的添加到分电这个宝贝里,那可以用这个。
其他的比如说价格的一些变动,包括组图,组图的变动,其他组图,
就是这是第一张首图,这是相当于后面几张,其他除了第一张之外的组图。
然后这边是属性图片,就是说颜色的那些图片。
还有描述,电脑描述,手机描述,这些都是可以去选择的同步。
因为这里还有一个实时同步,如果您勾选了,
那么在这个同步之后的话,会自动把给这两个商品生成,
实时同步出所需要的那个关联关系并且开始后续的话,
这两个商品会开启实时同步。
这个您根据需求来选。
我们先来选择一下库存和SQ来做一个测试。
在这里的话,您可以随时查看,进行或者说编辑,或者删除这条规则。
接下来我们来进行走动同步,选择商品同步,
然后这里有源店铺,您要把哪个店铺的商品给同步过去呢?
比如说现在选择主店,比如说我要把这个商品给同步过去,
点击立即同步。
我要给店铺二这边的同步,选择刚才这个规则,
在这里的话您也可以查看这个规则或者进行编辑。
好了,那接下来您自己点击一下确定,那就会把主店的这个SQ,比如说多了几个SQ,
就可以同步到同步更新给分店了。
这里提示提交成功,去查看这个同步,任务。
如果这个任务的话,还没有开始,您是可以随时测销的。
好了,您看一下,这里显示已经同步成功,那么点击这个任务的ID,可以跳转到这个同步纪录,
您可以查看这是刚才手动同步的那么一条纪录,从源店铺的某个商品同步给分店铺的某个商品。
看它的编号是多少,同步状态以及时间,都可以看到,可以导出同步纪录,同样的话如果有失败的,您可以直接把失败的查询出来,点击重新同步,可以对这些失败的进行重新的同步。
好了,这些就是给大家介绍的手动同步数据,谢谢。